fetishes I did talk to a researcher who
had who got interested fetishes are
something like ten times more prevalent
in males and in females so somebody did
actually tried say this was at ut-austin
tried to create a fetish by showing
sexually stimulating images while the
voice of the head of the psychology
department was playing in the background
so they it was like I think it was sort
of an in-joke on campus they like they
wanted to get the students also sexually
aroused by the voice of the head of the
chairman because so they really tried
then they did is they did a study with
like pictures of boots and shoes and
they were yes able to create an arousal
response to a boot you know you can you
can't create fetishes pretty pretty
easily it's much easier with men than
with women for some reason anyway but
they tried to get there was a hello
welcome to the psychology department of
this guy's voice and they tried very
hard to get with the situation where all
the students like he had would follow
him around just sort of